a full-grown great white versus a  full-grown polar bear in an  olympic-sized swimming pool that is  seven feet deep and 75 degrees  fahrenheit who wins great white  polar bears wait that's way too warm way  too warm of water for a polar bear 75  degrees way too warm for a polar bear  way too warm for a polar bear  yeah that's not a polar bear's natural  environment no it isn't he might die  that's what i think that's what i think  yeah i mean i don't know if great whites  like to swim in super warm water either  but i just feel like polar bears got it  like they love the cold it's not like  you see great whites in the arctic  big brain [ __ ]  sharks are still quicker but it's not  it's not a  boxing match i mean it's gonna be when  this [ __ ] polar bear gets his paws on  you okay  i don't know man  great white